من منا لا يحب اشراقه الشمس في يوم جميل
عندما تطل علينا ببهائها الجذاب لتملا
الارض نورا ودفئها لكن عندما تزيد الحراره
عن معدلاتها الطبيعيه قد تشكل خطرا حروق
الشمس وضربات الشمس والجفاف كلها مشاكل
محتمله مع زياده الحراره قد يكون اجراء
بحث في هذه التاثيرات الضاره على اجسام
البشر في الحياه الحقيقيه امرا صعبا ولهذا
لدينا الروبوت اندي للقيام بهذه المهمه
وبمفرده
هناك بعض التجارب التي تريد القيام بها مع
البشر وهناك الكثير منها لا تريده حقا لان
شخصا ما قد يتعرض للاذى لذلك على سبيل
المثال لا احد يقيس زياده درجه حراره
الجسم الاساسيه لشخص يصاب بضربه الشمس لكن
باستخدام الدميه يمكننا في الواقع محاكاه
الظروف
ومعرفه مدى سرعه زياده درجه الحراره
الاساسيه
عندي شبيه بالانسان يشعر بالحراره ويتعرق
يستخدمه الباحثون في جامعه ولايه اريزونا
لدراسه تاثيرات الحراره الشديده على جسم
الانسان يحتوي عندي على 35 مساحه سطحيه
مختلفه يتحكم في كل جهاز بشكل فردي
باستخدام اجهزه لاستشعار درجه الحراره
واخرى لاستشعار تدفق الحراره
ومسامه للتعرق معا يمكن للباحثين محاكاه
الظروف الجويه المختلفه
هذه هي غرفه المناخ حيث نتحكم في درجه
الحراره والرطوبه لاعاده انتاج اي بيئه
موجوده على الارض حتى نتمكن من محاكاه
الرياح ودرجات حراره الهواء المختلفه
والرطوبه النسبيه الان يمكننا ان نرى
انديه تعرق من خلال هذه المسام الدقيقه
الموزعه على سطحه وهي تتعلق بطريقه تحاكي
جسم الانسان سؤال رئيسي يريد الباحثون
الاجابه عنه ماذا يحدث للجسم اثناء ضربه
الشمس
ونبحث ايضا في المزيد من الاشياء
التطبيقيه مثل كيف يرفع جسم شخص ما درجه
حرارته الاساسيه عندما يتعرض لبيئه قاسيه
قد يكون هذا الشخص عامل بناء في الخارج او
مجردا يعيش في الشارع الفكره هي قياس
مسارات التعرض للحراره المختلفه حتى نتمكن
بعد ذلك من العوده ويمكن للروبوت اجراء
تعديلات ومعرفه يمكن ان يكون تدخلا مفيدا
لمحاوله تفادي وصول شخص ما الى وضع حرج
ليست الفكره وراء اندي جديده فالدمى
الحراريه المعروفه ايضا باسم المانيكل
تستخدم بشكل شائع من قبل المصممين لتحسين
التحكم في درجه الحراره في الملابس ولكن
هذا واحد من اثنين فقط من اجهزه الروبوت
التي تستخدمها المؤسسات البحثيه والاول
الذي يمكن استخدامه في الاماكن الخارجيه